[Music]
now a drama of shakespearean proportions
is unfolding
north of the border alex simond and
nicholas sturgeon used to be political
soul mates
she lived up to him he mentored her she
was his designated successor as first
minister
now simon is accusing his former protege
not just of misleading or even lying to
the scottish parliament
but being part of a scottish government
and snp
cabal designed to destroy him
sturgeon says there's not a shred of
evidence to support
his claims but her crown office has
censored key parts of his evidence
and her snp is arguing strongly that it
should not be published
of course it already has been by the
spectator
so why the fuss you might ask reasonably
well here's the answer because unless
the parliamentary inquiry
also publishes the evidence the inquiry
cannot consider it
when it comes to its conclusions clever
to break down the significance of this
week's events i'm joined by fraser
nelson the spectator's editor katie
balls
spectators deputy political editor and
alex masley our scotland editor
welcome to you all let's go straight
north of the border first alex
give us an update is alex salmond
now going to testify before the
parliamentary inquiry tomorrow
uh all the indications are that he is
going to appear
uh tomorrow friday morning but then of
course all the indications have been
that he would appear
on several previous occasions and
something at the last moment has always
come up that has made it
impossible for him to do so however this
time we are assured that he will
testify before the committee tomorrow uh
and then next week
nicola sturgeon will have her say at
long last her appearance
having been postponed on as many as half
a dozen
occasions as this committee has tried to
to make
its tortuous way through a sort of
morass of treacle
um and made very little headway while
trying to do so
uh so this is after two
two and a half three years of this saga
finally coming to a head
and the implications are possibly
explosive
um it is entirely possible that this
could one day be seen as the
as as the few days in which nicola
sturgeon's
career comes to an abrupt end and with
it the all sorts of
uh knock-on consequences not just for
may's hollywood election
but for scotland and the future of the
united kingdom
itself i mean it is it is a fairly big
deal
if mr simon does appear and i perfectly
take your point we've been here before
on many an occasion and it hasn't
happened
but if it does this time alex
will he do we know yet if he will be
allowed to
speak to those parts of his submission
which the crown office wanted redacted
and parliament has
redacted because the parts that have
been censored if you like
really go to the heart of the claims
he's making against nicholas sturgeon
about misleading parliament
uh absolutely i mean one has to think
that
that the committee will be able to
inquire about this because
otherwise it seems to me that the point
of having mr salmond appearing is
sharply reduced or diminished and you're
right
that the committee is charged with
investigating just how the scottish
government managed to botch its own
investigation into the first two
complaints that were made by civil
servants against alex salmond
a procedure that he took to judicial
review
where the judge ruled that it was
unlawful
and tainted by apparent bias that is
what the committee is investigating they
are not interested they are not capable
they are not charged with investigating
the grounds for those complaints against
salmon or the details of what took place
between him and
and various women ah but therefore as a
part of that
that one of the key questions it seems
to me um
is what did the first minister know
about this investigation and when did
she know it
she insists that she knew nothing of it
until april the 2nd
2018 when she was informed of it by alex
salmond
himself at a meeting at her house in
glasgow
now there is evidence from court and
other other areas which suggests that
actually nicola sturgeon knew about this
some days previously um and that
there was a meeting between alex
salmon's former chief of staff
and the first minister and members of
her office which was arranged
by the first minister's office precisely
to discuss
the investigation into the complaints
against salmon and that and the
the the the charges against him so if
that is the case
and we only have mr salmon's word and
those of his allies for it
then to the layman it looks as though
nicola sturgeon has been guilty of
misleading parliament and the media on
multiple occasions
um now she will argue that it's only
three or four days and it doesn't really
matter here very much but
it seems to me that it is quite possible
for nicola sturgeon to have had a much
greater awareness
of this investigation for some weeks
perhaps even months earlier than she
has hitherto said and that means that
really it is her
integrity her truthfulness that is the
matter for inquiry
uh in this regard um and and that it
seems to me poses a rather greater
problem for her
well certainly knowing weeks in advance
i i think it would be
reasonable to conclude alex could come
to the meeting
on this this crucial month of march
leading up to the
meeting on april the 2nd 2018 with
alexander in glasgow
which turned out to be a government
meeting rather than a party meeting
as originally claimed because her
husband turned up at the house but
didn't go to the meeting because
he thought it was a party a government
meeting and he's chief executive of the
party and didn't belong there
but we know that the meeting that was
fixed between
jeff aberdeen mr simon's former chief of
staff
and alex uh and and nicolas sturgeon
in hollywood in the first minister's
office the
that in itself had been the arrangements
for that had begun
with jeff aberdeen meeting her nicholas
sturgeon's chief of staff
at the beginning of march now surely it
beggar's belief
that her chief of staff would not have
said in fixing the meeting with jeff
aberdeen that the
he's coming to see you first minister it
should be beggar's belief that
she wouldn't have said and it's to talk
about the complainants
against his behavior well i
rather agree with you there andre yes um
but then in the same way i find it
extremely difficult to believe that you
have in late
late uh 2017 two civil servants
register concerns and then subsequently
complaints
about their experiences at the hands of
alex salmond and i find it quite hard to
believe that nobody in the scottish
government
thinks it is sensible prudent or
necessary to inform the first minister
of this
um and yet that is something that we are
asked to believe
um i find that quite incredible um given
what i know about the closeness of the
uh snp about the way in which scottish
politics a very small
tightly knit circle of people in which
everybody knows everybody and everybody
knows a lot of other people's business
uh the way in which scottish public life
operates
leads me to think that it would be quite
extraordinary for the first minister
not to be included in some of those
discussions but that is what we are told
and
perhaps perhaps the first minister has a
satisfactory explanation for
all of this and she promises to deliver
that next week
she insists that at no point has she
done anything wrong or dubious or
improper
and that or her concern has always
solely been
to ensure that the complaints made
against her predecessor
are properly investigated that it would
have been a dereliction of duty
for her to have allowed those complaints
to go un
investigated if you like um and i think
people can agree on that obviously and
they can
further agree and accept that this was
obviously in many ways a very difficult
um uh moment and series of choices for
nicolas sturgeon to have to make
um but nevertheless the central issue at
play now is whether she has been telling
the truth to parliament or not and that
is quite distinct
from questions as to whether or not she
uh
you know sought to intervene in the
investigation
um you know so so you know the charge is
not actually one of any sort of
interference in the investigation
necessarily
but of not telling the truth or being
candid
about her involvement in the
investigation as
you know that old cliche you know the
cover-up is worse than the crime well
cliche cliches become such things for a
reason because they frequently contain
a degree of truth as you just said the
watergate question when did you know
what did you know and when did you know
it that was senator baker's
crucial question throughout the
watergate hearings uh
let me bring fraser in here now because
friends of this
something i think most of our viewers
won't understand
and that is that the scottish parliament
published alex simon's submission but
then under pressure from the crown
office
uh withdrew it agreed to a whole range
of redactions about some
quite crucial areas that alex and myself
have just been
talking about there and then republish
it with all these
redactions and yet
unredacted bar for one redaction the
whole submission
is on the spectator website people just
won't understand how these two things
fraser can exist in tandem
well there's two extraordinary things
about this the first is of course
why would you bother redacting something
already in the public domain
and the answer as you said earlier
andrew is that if it's not published in
their version of the inquiry
when alex salmond can't really talk
about it it basically
censors it not just from his evidence
but from the evidence he's about to give
tomorrow and also it gives if it's
published it gives him legal cover
if they've rejected it when alex simon
feels he'll be legally exposed because
it's not like westminster
where anybody can say anything in a
westminster inquiry in the house of
commons
they've got legal cover they've got
parliamentary privilege but it doesn't
exist in scotland
but the other extraordinary thing is
that the crown office is giving
instructions to parliament in the first
place
it's absolutely unthinkable but the
crown prosecution service
in um down here in london would be
telling the house of commons what they
can and can't publish
what lines of inquiry they should and
should not pursue they would regard it
as incendiary
if they would be given such advice and
from the director of public prosecutions
there was another point as well which
really comes to the the hearts
of the kind of separation of powers
issue here that the crown office
which dick gave his um apply the
pressure to the scottish parliament
has at its head the lord advocate who's
a member of nicholas george's government
who has sat in several cabinet meetings
with her
so here you've got a government minister
in charge of the crown office
giving the snp's message or the crown
office is
basically aligned with the snp now the
reason andrew that we
the spectator went to the high court was
to clear up beyond doubt
that there was no legal impediment to
the whole story being told
to the truth being pursued it cost us a
fair amount of money going to the high
court in getting that advice but you'd
think there that the crown office would
have no real justification
for saying to the scottish parliament no
no you've got to take away this and that
for legal reasons
because the high courts lady dorian had
made clear
that there were well there was no legal
impediment yet in defiance of the high
court
the crown office run by a member of
nicola sturgeon's government
has made this direction and the scottish
parliament has succumbed
so the question arises and also with
watergate
the other question of watergate was if
the american president is guilty of
something
could he be investigated was democracy
strong enough
in america to really follow the truth
wherever it left
the same question is being raised for
scotland now can the first minister
really be investigated
or would she have little powers leverage
she could pool that would thwart
that investigation unfortunately is
looking very much like the latter
i must say is among many remarkable
developments the
the idea that the crown office in in our
case
when it appeared before lady dorian i
think probably the second
uh most senior judge in scotland about
our case
it raised not no complaints about
us continuing to have posted this salmon
submission minus the i think it was
paragraph 26
that they wanted out we took that out
and yet when the scottish
parliament does it they go back fraser
to the palm and say no you can't put the
whole chunks of this you can't publish
even though they didn't raise that with
us and when the lord advocate yesterday
in the scottish parliament was asked
about this the head of the crime office
the person
as you say that sits in uh nicola
sturgeon's uh cabinet when he was asked
about what had changed
between not raising it in the spectator
case and then putting the the heavies on
the scottish parliament
uh a week or so later he just didn't
answer the question
well if exactly his whole performance
there just showed how unaccountable he
really is
to parliament all of his answers were
very cursory
and he just didn't feel accountable but
then under the scottish system he
basically
isn't they can get away with this there
is of course
absolutely no answer to the question he
was asked like if
they were worried that alex salmon's
evidence somehow transgressed the law
somehow and exposed the claimants to
identification
of course they'd be writing to us they'd
be asking us to take it down or they
might have mentioned it to the high
court when this exact case was being
considered
but right now the crown office can act
not only with impunity but without any
accountability
but don't even feel compelled to answer
the questions
when they're in parliament because the
wiring of devolution is such
that the executive whoever's in power
has got incredible um ability to do
pretty much whatever
they want and that's why this episode is
not chilling it's
so chilling it's not chilling because
what alex says alex salmon says is true
i've got no idea
of what he says is true or not it's
chilling because we're finding out how
easy it is to stop
parliament asking questions that the
government doesn't want
raised that's happened time and time
again shamelessly
and without any kind of come back at all
so far i want to bring katie in a minute
and then go back to alice before i do
the
the lord advocate could have answered
that question yesterday
but the answer i would believe the
correct answer
um would have caused yet another
crisis because i think the correct
answer is we don't care that the
spectators published it
the important thing is the scottish
parliament doesn't publish it or
or doesn't publish the redactions
because that means the inquiry
uh cannot question alex simon about
these redactions
cannot question nicola sturgeon about
the bits are redacted and
cannot take them into account when it
comes
to making its conclusions and yet that
part that was redacted is crucial
to alex simon's claim that the first
minister
misled parliament but he's not there in
the scottish parliament
and my understanding is can be discussed
katie let me bring me in alex
quite rightly said in a sense that there
are two
main criticisms alex simon or
accusations
alex simon makes of nicholas sturgeon
one that she
lied to or the very least misled
the scottish parliament over the what a
great question what did you know and
when did you uh
know it and the second is that she was
part of a kind of cabal
trying basically to destroy alex
sturgeon let's park that one
and go back to the misleading parliament
in london in westminster almost
certainly if a prime minister was found
to have done this
it's a resigning matter are you clear
there would be one in the scottish
parliament
no i think the expectation would be that
nick of the sturgeon if she has found to
mr said parliament uh is
as you say a resignation offense i think
it is widely seen as that human lead
parliament
even in westminster though when we
recently had a minister in former pretty
patel and the ministerial code
wasn't completely clear that that was
followed and but but i do think if you
speak to
figures in scotland scottish
conservatives they think this is
becoming increasingly damaging for
nicolas sturgeon
but do they think this is going to be
the end of her career
look everything is possible but i get
the
greatest sense that they see this as
something that could cause a serious
dent in terms of the snp's reputation
nick of the sturgeon's reputation
personally
and it could be the start of an
unraveling uh rather than that moment
but it's unpredictable times of course
so there is always that chance but i
think
all the things we've seen so far in
terms of the
push to make sure the scottish
department cannot look or ask certain
questions shows what you are up against
when it comes to what you would expect
to be
the right thing to do alex what's your
view in
in what i guess we should say is the
unlikely event that the
parliamentary inquiry is quite explicit
that the first minister
did mislead or even lie to parliament
would she have to resign if that was the
conclusion
well ordinarily yes i mean you know
first ministers have had to resign for
much lesser offenses than that and other
scottish political figures even in the
short history of the scottish parliament
have also seen their careers
terminated for much uh flimsier offenses
than anything that nicholas sturgeon
might credibly be accused of
um and so you know if you view it from
those in that sense that you know there
is ample precedent for her going but
you know these are not the usual
circumstances
um this is an extraordinary situation
and an extraordinary moment
in scottish history too you know there
is a election to
holly roode in may um an opinion poll
out today shows a little bit of
fragmentation
the snp support but still suggests that
the party would win
uh an overall majority in that uh
election with all that then entails in
terms of
uh the national question about
independence the future of the united
kingdom and so on and remember for
for an awful lot of voters that is a
much much more important and bigger
question
than the fate of nicola sturgeon or
whether she's telling the truth or not
um and so i suspect that she might
well feel that she could tough it out if
you like um
because if she does if she makes it
clear that she wouldn't be going
anywhere
well who's actually going to do anything
who is in a position to
to actually change that reality and it's
not clear to me that there would be
anybody
in a position to do that um you know
that obviously if it would be the case
would i think further undermine and
tarnish the respectability and the
authority
of the scottish parliament and of
scottish politics more generally
but it is an unavoidable truth that
this is now becoming a very partisan
fight
it's not just a question of establishing
the truth of what happened or maybe
didn't happen
in this whole rather squalid affair it
has become a partisan fight with
conservative and labor msps uh you know
demanding nicola sturgeon's head
essentially because they see
that this scandal might deliver it to
them in a way that the electorate damned
them
will not ask you this alex then i got a
fraser and then
i can let you two get on with your day
and
i'll keep katie hostage because i want
to ask her about what's happening inside
downing street about the union
so my question to you is this alex for a
lot of this story
because you began by saying it's been
around for a long while
but it's been very much a kind of
hollywood bubble story it hasn't had
huge cut through to the general public
partly because
the scottish media has been curiously
reluctant to do much about it
am i right to detect that that's
changing a bit now
that the scottish media is doing a lot
more on this
and that it is because mr salmon
and nicola sturgeon are now daggers
drawn publicly attacking each other
publicly
that it's beginning now to have cut
through to the wider electorate
i i think on that latter point it has to
because you know you suddenly see
you know the bbc taking an interest you
see the london broadsheets
taking an interest uh you know having
largely ignored this story for
for you know two two and a half years um
so you know you know plenty of people in
scotland have obviously been writing a
lot about
it um over the last period of time but
it has been difficult
to for to for the story to get much cut
through partly because it is very
complicated
um you know there isn't necessarily a
single soundbite charge to be leveled
against nicolas sturgeon until alexamen
supplies it but then his
his charge against her is so
extraordinary it involves the
complete corruption of almost every
facet of scottish public life
if true it would be truly monstrous but
it is such a
such a large claim that i think plenty
of people will think well could that
possibly actually be
true um but nevertheless you know
this is now bubbling up you know it is
unavoidable partly because you finally
have
um the the pair of them if you like
getting in the ring together like uh
like a boxing match that has been
scheduled or rumored for a long long
long period of time without ever
actually
quite being made now it is being made
and so now is the time for people who
haven't been paying attention
for the last couple of years and i
understand why they might not have been
because plenty of other things have been
happening in the world i mean
we have had this pandemic thing um you
know
but now is the time for for even people
who have not been paying attention
enough until now
to actually do so because it is a proper
heavyweight contest
and frasier my final question to you i
mean westminster
hasn't even been a spectator in this
it's largely ignored it
until perhaps the past couple of weeks i
mean i noticed
liam fox uh from scottish but
tory representing an english consistency
raising it in the commons yesterday
saying
the the the the scottish devolution
uh system was created by the house of
commons by the westminster parliament
so don't we have any uh say over what is
going on there don't we have any
powers of scrutiny or oversight i
thought that was interesting
and i wrote in in an article that you
know
if if texas was behaving in this sort of
way
the u.s government would have sent in
the feds by now to look at first
amendment rights breaches and
various other things i mean is
westminster getting more interested
fraser
yes and what i thought was particularly
interesting was the reply
that liam fox got from the then deputy
speaker eleanor lang also ascot
she was saying that yes this house the
house of commons is always concerned
about
keeping up the standards of democracy a
hint
that the house of commons as an
institution might well take an interest
in its creation the scottish parliament
to see if things have gone wrong
there now you see this is a theme
amongst not just
the scots in parliament but all
ministers they're working out that if
they care about the
uk as much as the s p cared about
scotland they should of course
be feeling the pain of a nervous system
of an island if something goes wrong
in scotland it should absolutely
resonate in westminster
now katie reveals in her cover piece for
this week's magazine
that there are now plans to use powers
seen at brexit for the uk government to
go into scotland and start to sponsor
more things directly
for example it could say okay there's
huge drugs deaths in glasgow
so maybe we can work with the glasgow
council to come up with more treatment
centers so the council would appeal
directly to westminster for funding it
might not get
from edinburgh and in that way the uk
government can be a little bit more
a uk government rather than seeing
scotland as a foreign country
of which it knows little and understands
less
well let's see if they do i think it's
now got their
attention and the way it didn't have
even two or three weeks ago
uh fraser alex i know you're both busy
i'm going to let you go
but i'm going to hold on to katie for
just a little bit more because
katie's done the cover story of the
spectator this week and it's
about what's been happening inside 10
downing street vis-a-vis the union
uh you would think perhaps that with a
kind of civil war
going on in scotland at the very top of
the snp
that would be good news for the unionist
cause and in theory it
probably is a bit however downing
street's been having its own civil war
over how to
keep the union how to handle the snp how
to put the cause
for the union and katie has written
about that to
tell us more katie because it would seem
that there's
actually been deep divisions in downing
street over
how to meet the nationalist threat
yes uh not to be outdone the westminster
government have kept themselves
rather busy with their own factional
infighting in recent weeks
and we have a situation where that is
now affecting the union policy
um so uh there have been various reports
over the weekend about boris johnson's
court or queen carries court depending
on
who you read um but ultimately what
happened last friday was that oliver
lewis
resigned as the head of the union unit
after just uh two weeks in the job
uh and earlier that month that actually
lost luke graham as head of the union
unit
so two gone in one month which i think
does just point to the
disharmony when it comes to how you get
a
coherent union strategy in downing
street that works with other departments
now the departure of oliver lewis was as
much to do with personalities
and the vote leave faction at the rise
of the govites or friends of carrie
simmons
and it all are boiling up but when you
uh look at where that leaves us
now there's a situation where oliver
lewis had a strategy one that he was
supposed to present to government
advisors um the evening that he
instead quit his job which is an
aggressive strategy to take on the snp
try and stop them from winning a
majority in the scottish parliament
elections
close the door firmly on a referendum
have a 40-person strong union unit
a little bit like a vote leave campaign
uh some would say
um but this this is all gone now and
instead we are
getting a cabinet committee the end of
the union unit as far as we can tell or
at least as we have known it
and a debate has reopened on how exactly
you should have this message
on on the union a gov approach which is
a softer approach
or a more confrontational one and i have
to say right now very few people know
so despite this change of personnel i
understand there's oliver lewis that you
write about mccover's story he was meant
to be
heading up the sort of the union union
he was only in the job for two weeks
or something there was as you say this
disagreement
michael golf hailing from aberdeen
himself wanting to love bomb the scots
with the union propaganda
uh mr lewis wanting a much take no
prisoners
much tougher line in dealing with the
snp
and the and the separatists
we've seen he's now gone his predecessor
went before that
michael gove's position seems to change
every second week in terms of what he
does for this
government we don't know yet you're
telling us katie
what the johnson government strategy is
for preserving the union no
cabinet ministers believed they
understood the strategy because oliver
lewis has started to present it to them
i think there are some that quite like
this strategy because i thought it was
simple
it wasn't a too overly intellectual it
would uh you know finally take a tough
approach to the snp
no more apologizing no more devolution
things like that
or you know giving more powers and but
now you have a point where it does
appear that michael gove's position is
in the ascendancy on the union
we're hearing that boris johnson might
soften his tone
start talking about a reckless
referendum rather than a
never referendum and i think as soon as
you start talking about a reckless
referendum you're moving to the michael
gove approach which is
say no to a referendum but because it is
not the time now
rather than there can never be a
referendum because it was once in a
generation
which is more than lewis view and there
is a cabinet committee where we are
going to see the prime minister
take charge apparently this is now the
time for him to take charge on the union
and different views amongst the
ministers on it so i still think that if
you look at it in the sense that
it really is a perilous moment for boris
johnson if nicolas sturgeon wins the
majority and the scottish parliament
elections
matters at the point in a way could be
taken out of his hands it becomes an
issue of legality it could go to the
courts
so this is a very important time yet
there is no
cohesive uh strategy or agreement right
now and and
we still seem to be vaguely in the
debate stage
there is one area final question do you
care where a light bulb seems to have
gone on in downing street
or in government and that is that it's
it's suddenly dawned on them properly
because they all belong to the
department of slow learners
that it doesn't matter how much money
extra money you pump into scotland
if you do it through the scottish
government run by the snp
they will say two things one they'll
take the credit for the money
when they spend it and secondly they'll
say it's not enough
doesn't matter how much is it's not
enough so we get the credit for spending
it
but by the way it's not enough because
that miserable westminster didn't give
us as much
as we need they've now realized that in
the way the european union used to spend
money directly and you would
see the little european union flag
brought to you by the european
commission or whatever
that the london government is going to
spend money directly in scotland
is that correct yes and this is an area
where there is broad agreement
but again a disagreement on tone but
ultimately special powers from brexit
from the
internal market bill i mean the uh what
one idea that boris johnson is very keen
on
is the idea of local councils being able
to apply directly to westminster for
funding for projects
and as you say you cut out the scottish
parliament but it's not so much a power
grab
so it could be accused of this because
it's an additional thing and so
you could say we are funding this uh you
know this drug center in glasgow because
you need that role and taking
powers away is adding powers on in terms
of what westminster can do
um and it has a lot of support i think
the question is do you say it in the
sense of
we are funding this drug center because
the smp is useless and that's why we've
stepped in
that's one approach all the gove
approach i think would say we're funding
this because
uh we at westminster love scotland and
you deserve it
they still have a lot to decide yes it's
quite clear including who's actually
gonna
head up uh the pro-union campaign
uh katie thanks for joining us a great
cover story it really takes the lift off
the lid off what's been happening inside
downing street so it's well worth the
[Music]
read
[Music]
you